The wait is finally over.
My bowl of ramen has arrived...
...and I think this might be the most beautiful bowl of ramen...
...that has ever been on the table before me.
But what's really impressing me as I just sat here waiting for my bowl...
...is just the care that they put into making the ramen here.
There are only three people running this entire restaurant...
...and they just do everything with expertise...
...like, artisan; yeah, they're really artisan ramen makers.
The noodles look perfect.
The decoration, just look how beautiful this is.
And this is just a really normal restaurant, but just look at that care.
Everything is arranged beautifully.
These are pieces of chashu, really just unbelievable tender-looking.
And then over here, it almost looks like,...
...I'm not sure if that's chicken or that's pork, but that came out of the wok.
He fried this up in a wok.
There's half of an egg here.
There are onions, these are shreds of, I'm not sure what that is.
There are green onions on this side...
...and just marvel at the thickness and the richness of that broth.
I gotta taste that broth first before I do anything.
Oh, that is absurd!